So mal gucken ob das jetzt tut, ja, Bild geht, exellent.
So, bevor wir das Synology Zeug installieren können Leute, haben wir noch ein bisschen
was vor uns und zwar müssen wir das Board erstmal wiederbeleben, weil das Board ist
kaputt.
Ah nee, ich muss erstmal warten bis der Twitch Stream überhaupt on ist.
Keg Tribble you.
Ups, falsch die Mode, egal es ist eh noch keiner da.
So, ähm, gucken ob die Musik passt oder ob das zu nervig wird, je nachdem was sie da
drin haben.
Dann müssen sie ein bisschen mehr Actionkünstler sein, was haben die hier, ich brauche erst
die passende Musik untermalen, sonst geht das nicht, aaah, ja das geht doch, ja, können
wir sie lauter machen, exellent, so, ja jetzt hat es Twitch auch kapiert, dass der Stream
on ist.
Und ja Leute, wir haben so ein kleines Problem, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was wenn ich das
Board anmache, aber wobei ihr seht es hier oben rechts, oder mal gucken ob ihr es oben
rechts seht, ähm, wenn ich das Board anmache, dann geht es gleich wieder aus, aber wir müssen
das Board nehmen, weil ich habe sonst kein anderes Board für was ich RAM da habe, mit
parallel, das ist exquisite Hardware hier, die Auflösung könnte bisschen höher sein,
aber da kann ich da nichts dran machen, weil die Auflösung ist, warte mal, ich meine
die Auflösung ist relativ gut, das ist von einem iPhone aufgenommen, was hier am Arsch
der Welt liegt, ähm, aber trotzdem, übrigens wenn ich den Sound hier nicht ausmache, pass
mal auf, Test, Test, da hört man mich, das sackt, also man erkennt leider nicht so, so
richtig, oh, warte mal, ich darf das nicht so sehr verschieben, sonst verschiebt sich
das Bild oben auch, MonkaS, muss so bleiben, so zumindest, naja, wer sich fragt was das
hier in der Mitte ist, das hier in der Mitte ist ein M2 auf Pizzi Express, sowas gibt es
wirklich, ähm, und das ist halt das einzige Board was ich hab, wo ich noch RAM für hab,
das ist glaube ich DDR3 RAM oder so, und ich glaube auch nur 4G, das Board selbst ist
relativ neu, das Board geht, das ist, ähm, ich zeig euch mal was das für ein Board ist,
das ist, das ist relativ, ich kanns euch auch hier zeigen, das ist relativ neu, das ist
ein, ähm, Gigabyte D2P, ähm, hier, das, das da, das ist relativ neu, also, na gut,
das ist relativ neu, das ist 3 Jahre alt oder so, also alte Hardware triffts eigentlich
ganz gut, ähm, aber es ist Low-End, es ist Low-End Hardware, so, äh, das da, das ist
das Board, und das hat was, das ist sogar DDR4, guck mal, da konnte man sogar, da konnte
man sogar sich noch einen RAM für kaufen, falls man das weiter, weiter betreiben will,
ähm, DDR4 ist übelst billig grad, ne, spinnt, oh mein, spinnt das Mikro, echt, machts das,
also, ich, ich müsste eigentlich alles richtig eingestellt hab, das sollte eigentlich nix
spinnen, also, meine Vorschau ist auch okay, Test, Test, Test, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
ne, ne, ne, passt alles, müsste eigentlich, müsste eigentlich alles gut, gut funktionieren,
ja, so, ähm, das heißt, ich hab das ganze übrigens jetzt angeschlossen an meine Elgato
Capture Card, das heißt, wir können auch, wir können auch gucken, was passiert, das
größte Problem, was ich aktuell hab, ist, dass das Mainboard nicht angeht, ich zeig
euch mal, was passiert, wenn man das Mainboard anmacht, ich mein, ihr sehts ja oben, ihr
sehts ja oben im, was, was willst du dann, skip, ich will das nix neues installieren,
ihr sehts ja oben rechts, passt mal auf, ich schalt jetzt mal an, ups, äh, ich kanns
auch, ich kanns auch im Fullscreen machen, habt das in klein und groß, ich schalt mal
kurz an, und da werdet ihr feststellen, ne, da steckt, ich hab den Stecker schon ein paar
Mal rein rausgemacht, das bringt nix, wartet mal ab, das, äh, Schattenleak, ja, das sieht
ganz schön kaputt aus, ich mach nochmal kurz aus und dann wieder an, aber ich hab ne Idee,
was wir machen können, ich hab ne Idee, ich hab nämlich BigBrain mir Gedanken dazu gemacht,
und zwar, es könnte einfach sein, dass das Board gar nicht kaputt ist, sondern, dass
man das einfach einschalten muss, klingt jetzt erst mal ultra naheliegend, aber ich
hab das Board eigentlich so eingestellt, dass es sich automatisch einschaltet, nachdem es
angeht, aber es könnte ja sein, dass die BIOS-Settings hinüber sind, man weiß ja nie, ne, weil zumindest
ich, ich mach nochmal an, also wie gesagt, ihr seht ja auch hier oben den Lüfter, der
Lüfter vom Netzteil, der geht ja auch an, gleich wieder aus, gleich wieder aus, was
ziemlich sackt, also CPU, Stromstecker und so ist alles dran, ich glaube, ne, der Stream
ist doch eben gerade das On gekommen, Pad, 1HD, also, ich glaube, wir müssen einfach
einstellen, achso, ihr seht, seht ihr den, seht ihr hier, ja doch, ihr seht das Netzteil
hier, sieht man doch, man hat auch gesehen, dass das anläuft, da wieder ausgeht, so,
und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, wir suchen jetzt einfach mal das Handbuch von dem Netzteil
raus, deswegen ist es ganz gut, dass wir es schon aufgemacht haben und gucken mal, wo
man da überhaupt den Power-Stecker dran machen muss und dann kommt das nächste Problem,
da kommt das nächste Problem, ich hab kein Schalter, aber dafür finden wir auch was,
ich hab da auch schon eine Idee, ne, mit einem Stück Metallkutschließen hab ich schlechte
Erfahrungen gemacht, wahrscheinlich bin ich zu grobmotorisch dafür veranlagt, ich hab
ne andere Idee, ich hab ne andere Idee und ich wette mit euch, wenn ich euch meine Idee
zeige, dann keckt sich das Stream wieder ein ab, so, also jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken,
ob es da irgendwie ein Handbuch oder so für das Board gibt, Manual, nein gibt's nicht,
Unterstützung, warum ist das auf Deutsch die Seite, können wir die umstellen, EN, ah yes,
da steht auf dem Board steht nix, ich glaub man erkennt es in der Kamera nicht, ne, also
hier vorne steht nix, Unterstützung, ne, ne, da muss keine, da muss keine, da muss keine
GPU drin sein, das war es, also mal ganz davon abgesehen, da ist ja ein Onboard, Handbuch,
exellent, Englisch, jawoll, also gucken wir uns das ganze mal an, was da so im Handbuch
drin steht, wie man das Ding wieder ankriegen, so, bla bla bla bla bla, F-Panel, Braumer F-Panel,
so also, Mainboard, wo, ah hier, ne, ne, das ist der ATX Stecker, wo ist denn das Panel,
hier, also, man braucht, für den Power Knopf muss man da dran, so die Frage ist jetzt nur
auf welcher Seite ist das, also ich muss auf der linken Seite, zweite von unten muss da
der Power Switch dran, zweite von unten ist Big Brain Reverse Engineering, da, oder, also
Innenseite, Innenseite, die zwei von unten, da wo zwei Pins drüber leer sind und schräg
gegenüber von dem einen leeren Pin, das kann man sich glaube ich ganz gut merken, so und
ich zeige euch mal die Idee, die ich habe, was wir machen, ich habe keinen Schalter, aber
ich habe mir gedacht wir können folgendes verwenden, ich halte es mal kurz in die Kamera,
Moment, warte mal, ich halte es mal kurz in die Kamera, wir können einfach zwei Jumper
Kabel verwenden und dann machen wir es so, guck, dann machen wir es so, warte mal, dann
machen wir es so, kommst du dir vor wie einer, der das Auto klauen will, und das ist unser
Schraubenersatz, dann nimmt man eine Pinzette, nein, nein, nein, nein, wir machen das so,
ok, also wo muss ich den Kram jetzt noch mal anschließen, da, ok Chat, Chat, ich schließe
es jetzt mal an, ich schließe es jetzt mal an, aber ich mache mal das Strom vorher,
ne, das Strom ist aus, ok, also mal anschließen, ich muss, ich muss, Chat, guck mal, guck mal
mit, ob ich es richtig anschließe, also ich glaube, man sieht es nicht richtig, da dran,
ich sehe nichts, es ist dunkel, ah, und, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
stimmt das jetzt, ist das richtig, huge, huge quali, man sieht alles, das könnte stimmen,
das könnte stimmen, Hand liegt, ja, das ist nichts Neues, das könnte stimmen, so Chat,
und jetzt schalten wir mal an, jetzt, ups, ich lasse das mal hier auf, jetzt schalten,
leider kann man mit dieser Kacke, kennt jemand von euch eine gute Kamera App fürs iPhone,
ich finde nichts gescheites, das, also was ich jetzt für die Kamera vom iPhone habe
ist das hier, irgendwie so heißt das Ding, das da, das hat aber bloß maximal 1720p mit
kacke Bitrate, dafür kriegt man das ganze halt per RTSP Stream, OBS Kamera, aha, was
ist das, ooooh, was ist das, wow, 16 Euro, das ist ganz schön, das ist ganz schön viel
Geld, was, letzte Preis, aber das ist auch, guck mal, man kann Licht anmachen, na vielleicht
ist es das doch irgendwo, man kann Licht anmachen, man kann es nicht, vielleicht kaufe
ich mir das für nächsten Stream, keine Ahnung, aber zumindest, wir testen jetzt ob es angeht
so, wir testen jetzt ob es angeht, Achtung, exquisite, es geht da wieder aus, ich habe
hier noch nichts gemacht, so und jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit ob das funktioniert,
oh nee, es ist wieder ausgegangen, äh, geht es wieder an, ich habe nichts gemacht, lasse
einfach mal die Finger von weg, mach das mal, sehr gut, es ist wieder angegangen, exellent,
ok, geht da schon mal recht abenteuerlich los das ganze, oh, guck mal da, wir haben
noch ein BIOS, 15.19 am 30.09.2019, ja, so sieht es aus Leute, wir machen jetzt erstmal
ein BIOS Reset, wir machen jetzt erstmal, oh, ich brauche dann noch eine zweite Tastatur,
fuck, habe ich noch eine zweite Tastatur, zweite Maus habe ich noch, habe ich noch meine Tastatur,
meine kaputte, irgendwo, ich habe ja vorher die Corsair Tastatur gehabt, die habe ich
aber jemand geliehen, während hier, während Corona, die habe ich gerade nicht da, ähm,
ich stöpsel einfach mal meine Tastatur da jetzt dran, warte mal kurz, hey, ich muss
entwirren, reicht das Kabel nicht, Wong KS, so, geht das, hallo, habe ich es falsch angestöpselt,
was ist denn jetzt schon wieder los, andere besser, jetzt geht die Tastatur, ne, ne, ja,
ich dachte auch, man muss neu starten, wäre mein nächstes gewesen, gut, hallo, kann das
mal fullscreen gehen, fullscreen please, fullscreen, exellent, wir machen mal, oh, kommt mal damit,
der wird sogar schon hier exquisite, wollen wir mal probieren, ob das einfach funktioniert,
USBboot, ne, ne, komm, wir machen, oder, sicher, dass deine BIOS Batterie nicht tot ist, doch
wahrscheinlich schon, komm, wir gucken mal, ob das USBboot hat, nein, macht es nicht, das
müsste, Moment, das müsste, nicht USB, was laber ich denn für ein scheiß PXEboot, das
müsste aber PXEbooten, weil ich bei mir eigentlich PXEboot drin habe, wir machen mal Restore
Falls, das kann nicht schaden, eine Runde Restore Falls und, ja, safe change, jawoll, alles gut,
nochmal neu starten, und dann stellen wir nochmal ein, mal gucken, was man überhaupt
alles einstellen muss, durability inside, haben sie gesagt, ok, also, der erkennt schon mal,
dass wir am Start sind, ja, Netzwerk, das ist doch schon mal gut, das kann man alles
booten, setup, prompt, timeout, boot, voll, was, was ich, das ist mir doch alles vollkommen
egal, was passiert, wenn man fastboot einschaltet, irgendwelche komischen, warum kriege ich nur
mit fastboot, Auswahl, wo ist denn der Sinn davon, wenn ich fastboot anmache, dass ich
dann eine Auswahl bekomme, warum habe ich nicht gerade umgedreht, bei keinem fastboot
eine Auswahl, hä, ok, billigboard, man weiß nie, so, müssen wir da irgendwas on board
laden, ist an, power, was auch immer das ist, soft power button off, so, was ich, ich will
eigentlich nur eine Sache einschalten, nämlich, dass wenn ich power ausschalte, dass er automatisch
wieder angeht, das geht irgendwo, mit Sicherheit, ich weiß aber nicht wo, das müssen wir uns
erstmal suchen, primary display integrate, was ist erp, das ist immer die beste Beschreibung,
das ist immer, das ist immer die geilste Beschreibung, erp, was ist erp, configure erp, ah, yes,
da weißt du sofort Bescheid, das ist, das ist, wisst ihr, da haben die Typen, da haben
die Typen, die den bios Hilfetext schreiben, die wissen es auch nicht, und naja, ok, trusted
computing, da kann man, brauchen wir sowas, äh, kann man auch anlassen, ist erp ein watt
stand by, ich hab, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ähm, ja, das kann alles da
bleiben, aber, naja gut, komm wir lassen die serial ports an, das starte ja nicht, hardware
monitor, pwm, pwm, das Ding hat nicht einen Lüfter, zio features, ah, guck mal, ac back,
ne, always on, always on, exellent, so, jetzt, jetzt sollte er wieder angehen, wenn er power
ausgeht, das müssen wir gleich ausprobiert, der fastboot ist doch dafür da, um das bios
zu überspringen, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf, was es genau alles macht,
base status juckt mich nicht, cpu configuration, socket 0, warum, warum geht das immer aus
dem fullscreen raus, ja gut, es ist halt, Drecks cpu, aber, es reicht, kann eh nix einschalten,
power management, naja, kann alles anbleiben, active cores, hä, active processor cores,
disabled oder enabled, was, wie darf ich mir denn das vorstellen, ist grad meine cpu aus
oder was, ok, was passiert, wenn ich das auf enabled stelle, ach, jetzt kann ich den zweiten
kern ausschalten, ok, die, also, die Beschreibung ist hochgradig unglücklich, ich, ich gehe
mal davon aus, wenn ich auf disabled stehe, sind einfach beide an, so, vtd machen wir
mal an, dass wir virtualisierungs zeug später testen können, nicht, dass wir viel virtualisieren
könnten mit zwei, ich sag mal, was ist denn hier los, warum kannst du nicht einfach mal
im fullscreen bleiben, bleibst du im fullscreen, fullscreen, wie soll ich denn vlc nutzen,
ich kann vlc neuerdings, ähm, elgato capture cards, so, thermal monitor können wir alles
anlassen, network stack, das müssen wir bestimmt einschalten, damit wir efiboot machen können,
was aber geil ist, was, also eben hat er doch efiboot das ding an, also wir machen es mal
an, die vlc kann elgato capture cards, wann das denn, ernsthaft, wie soll denn das funktionieren,
ok, ipv4 pxl support, excellent, einschalten, weil da kann ich gleich ne live cd booten,
csm configuration, ok, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, nvme configuration, no device found,
aber usb bleibt so, ok, viel mehr kann man eh nicht einstellen, das hält sich also in
grenzen, dann lassen wir das doch mal so, dann probieren wir jetzt mal aus, ob das automatisch
wieder angeht, oh man kann latchacy boot machen, das machen wir mal, vielleicht brauchen wir
das nämlich zum booten von meinem netzwerk, da bin ich, ah, das ist gut, weil ich glaube
ich kann kein efiboot machen, übers netzwerk, das spackt rum, das stellen wir mal lieber
auf latchacy netzwerk, alles klar, exquisite, und dann schauen wir mal ob der jetzt netzwerk
boot macht, kann man einstellen, dass der mit netzwerk anfangen soll, egal, gucken wir mal
ob der jetzt versucht netzwerk boot zu machen, huge stomp, oh, paused champ, paused champ,
der macht netzwerk boot, guckt euch das mal an, oh mal gucken ob er das hinkriegt, ich
glaube das klappt einfach, guckt euch das mal an, das pxe einfach so klappt, ok, wollen
wir mal eine live cd starten, debian, irgendwas, debian booster, jawoll, lxde, xfce, da kommt
man besser mit klar, it just works, guckt mal da, einfach netzwerk boot, dazu kann ich
ja im endeffekt wirklich jetzt nur sagen, hast du einen dienst, den du verbooten hast,
ja ich habe einen pxe container bei mir laufen, ich habe aber ehrlich, ich habe noch nie davon
eine echte hardware gebootet, nur vms, ich habe immer nur vms gebootet, ok exquisite
high octane gameplay hier, eine maus muss ich ja nur anschließen, eine warte mal, eine
zweite maus habe ich, wobei wir brauchen dafür keine maus, aber ich hätte im zweifelsfall
eine zweite maus, zweite tastatur habe ich halt nicht, vielleicht kann man das ja auch
mit dem controller steuern, ich habe noch einen xbox 2 usb, habe ich noch, der trend
geht zur zweiten maus, wenn das der trend ist, dann geht der trend bei mir zur siebten
maus oder so, ok während der lädt, probieren wir das mal aus, ob wir es hinkriegen, vlc,
ach moment, da muss ich erst einmal, ich muss die tastatur wieder umstöpseln, dass ich
jetzt mal die testung, ok, so, was, wie macht man das jetzt mit vlc, vlc, doch doch das
problem ist, wenn man die elgato capture card in obs einbindet, dann spackt die teilweise
rum, wenn man zähnen wechselt, deswegen mache ich es lieber über vlc, weil dann sehe ich
ja das nicht, wenn es im obs ist, da muss ja ein obs im obs aufmachen und so, das ist
ein open capture device, so, nope, also er macht irgendwas, aber ich sehe nichts, open
capture device, vielleicht muss ich, ich muss das elgato ding zumachen, ich muss bestimmt
das, was hat der für schmerzen jetzt, link becomes ready, ok, das geht bestimmt gleich
weiter, ich mache mal das elgato ding zu, vlc auf, open capture device, äh, nein, hm,
gleich webcam liegt, genau, tja, ich habe keine ahnung, mal gucken wie das geht, elgator
vlc, was, hast vielleicht den treiber nicht, naja, ich meine, die karte geht ja, ok, also,
öh, nö, nö, noch mal aus, hier vlc, open direct, ne, ja dann müssen wir uns wohl damit
zufrieden geben, dass wir, dass wir mal die elgator capture software gucken, ich kann
jetzt keine treiber inzuladen, muss ich mal neu starten, weil es windows ist, ne, dann
müssen wir uns hier drüber gucken, oh, live system image failed, das ist aber doof, warum
dann das, das sagt er aber mal richtig, warum konnte der jetzt das nicht booten, ok, ich
muss die tastatur wieder umstöpseln, leute, ich brauche echt eine zweitastatur, so, warum
konnte der das jetzt nicht booten, was hat der für schmerzen, ok, wir booten jetzt
was anderes, gucken wir mal, ob der irgendwas gebootet kriegt, what, wie bios, nicht bios,
override, genau, das zwar will ich booten, vielleicht hat er probleme wegen fehlender
tastatur, kann ich mir eigentlich vorstellen, das wäre schon ziemlich, gibt es doch mainboard,
die kein synology unterstützen, keine ahnung, ich wollte es ja auch grad nicht booten, ich
wollte irgendein x-beliebiges live linux booten und gucken ob es funktioniert, das sollte
eigentlich tun, also wenn wir prime same day delivery hätten, dann würde ich das tatsächlich
machen, ok, debian hat nicht funktioniert, was, was gibt es für eine schöne distribution,
ok, kali linux, komm wir booten kali, die für die hackermans unter uns, weil das dauert
ewig, ich brauch irgendwas was schnell geht, lxle, geht lxle schnell, komm wir booten kali
linux, ich brauch das, ich hab mal vorher in die anleitung reingeguckt, ich muss danach
in diesem linux hier, muss ich nen usb stick mir irgendwas aufschreiben zu, keine ahnung,
deswegen ich brauch eigentlich nur nen linux was bootet und ne shell, mehr brauch ich nicht,
ok jetzt ist ja exzellent spannend, ja debian hab ich grad gebooten, debian wollte nicht,
debian hat gesagt, moment ums genau zu sagen hat debian gesagt, ich wollte nicht das ich
boote, wobei das jetzt ja auch wieder ne debian ist, ähm wir probieren als nächstes irgendein
arch linux oder so, ich brauch hier ne live cd, irgendwas, vollkommen egal was, irgendwas
was gebootet ist und ne shell hat, weil ich hab vorhin schonmal in so ne anleitung kurz
reingeguckt, da stand man muss sich irgendwie aufschreiben an welchem port der usb, also
wie intern die id vom usb port ist, dazu brauch ich irgendwo ne, irgendeine live cd
soll ich nachgucken kann, auf mach hinne, ich will gucken ob ich es schaff auf diesem
ollen ding xpnology oder wie man das ausspricht zu installieren und das erste war erstmal
gucken ob das ding wieder funktioniert, das port wollte erst gar nicht booten, so weil,
ups oh Mist jetzt hab ich hier getippt, ich kann ja meine tastatur gar nicht verwenden,
da müssen wir big brain desktop switch machen, ha desktop switched, ne das ist ne kackeinleitung,
irgendwie in diese anleitung hab ich vorhin reingeguckt, keine ahnung ob das was taugt,
das ist ein bootloader für das sinology os und da kann man das sinology os quasi auf
irgendeinem linux ding installieren, so das machen wir alles nicht, das ist so ne komische
windows anleitung, die braucht kein mensch, jetzt hab, chat jetzt hab ich ein anderes
problem, jetzt komm ich nicht mehr aus der vorm raus ohne meine tastatur, jetzt okay
okay booten, booten please, okay booten, einfach booten, just boot, was hatte, alter was willst
du, warum kann er den kacke nicht booten, wo ist das problem, no supported files is the
image found at live, SSL certificate problem, what, warum das denn, SSL certificate not
valid, what the fuck was das denn, bios urzeit, oh big brain chat, die bios urzeit wird das
sein, ja genau, oh da hätt ich jetzt im leben nicht dran gedacht, sixhead ey, massive brain
chat, so, die stellt man hier was ein so, ne plus, ahja, was ist denn heute, vierte
zehnte, ach moment, das ist ami datum, pains champ, moment, ja doch vierte, freedom datum,
okay sonntag, ja das kommt hin, so und jetzt haben wir 16.44, naja nicht ganz, die bedienung
ist ja grausam, 44, excellent, wieder speichern, yes, was das, das hört sich an wie bayerische
dicke buckle music im hintergrundgrad, chat hat wieder richtig big brain, hab ich das
datum jetzt richtig eingestellt, hab sie mal mitgeguckt ob ich das richtig rumgemacht
hab, nicht dass er jetzt wieder abkackt, so live cds, was, was könnten noch schneller
gehen, fat dog 64, wie schnell ist denn so ein fedora, ja aber alpina hat kein live
image, manjaro, manjaro hab ich denn nie live gebootet, mal gucken was da passiert,
aber alpina hat er nicht drinnen, current stable, bam, xfce, architekt wäre auch nicht
schlecht, dann kriegen wir komplett, einfach shell und gut ist, gucken wir ob das jetzt
schneller geht, also ich hab hier den allesten, billigsten usb sticks aller Zeiten, ich hab
keinen anderen gefunden, irgendeinen 8 gigabyte, 15 jahre alten usb stick oder sowas, aber
es ist nicht wild, weil das xpnology glaubt nur 300mb oder so, absolut highspeed, so wir
müssen schon mal nebenbei lesen was wir eigentlich machen müssen während das hier bootet, so
ich kann jetzt leider hier nicht in vollbild wechseln, also was müssen wir machen, vorbemerkung,
gibt es dafür irgendeine ordentliche anleitung, nicht mit windows, sondern, ok, bla bla bla,
wie installiert man den kram, die machen hier irgendwelche sachen mit windows, ok, als erstes
muss man nämlich, als erstes lesen wir vendor id und product id aus, achso, ne das muss
ich gar nicht mehr livecd machen, das kann ich auch ohne probleme in der vm machen, brauche
ich die livecd vielleicht doch nicht, warum gibt es da nicht eine ordentliche anleitung
für linux, ja ich gehe gleich ins forum bei denen, wir schauen jetzt erstmal ob die manjaro
livecd bootet, oh jetzt hier, jetzt, jetzt müsste manjaroen auf, oh, oh, was jetzt,
ok der lädt noch irgendwie 30.000 sachen, das ist ungefähr so wie wenn man npm install
macht, der lädt auch das halbe internet erstmal, was lernen, was laden die da alles, mhwdfs,
alles klar, schonmal kein zertifikatsfehler ja, aber ok es sind bloß auch 48 sekunden
left, 49 sekunden left, 50 sekunden left, ich hab das gefühl es geht in die falsche
richtung, kann das ding mal aufhören aus dem fullscreen zu gehen, das regt mich übelst
auf, ok da gucken wir uns jetzt so an, das muss jetzt auch gehen, wir dürfen kein fullscreen
machen weil dann spackt er die ganze zeit rum, so wunderbar und das hier kann man übrigens
auch nicht verschieben, was auch immer das für komische, komische ui design hier sein
soll, ja das ist die software von der capturecard, so 29 sekunden, ne ich kann die, ich bewege
die maus ja nicht, aber die maus ist halt der meinung ok es gibt doch mal mini input
und schon ist das komplett aus dem fullscreen raus, ist ja nicht so als würde ich absichtlich
die maus hier irgendwie rum zappeln lassen, was ist hier unten, oh exellent ist ein bisschen
mehr platz, aber das andere kann man nicht ausplanten lassen, aber jetzt ist ein bisschen
mehr platz jetzt, alter will der mich verarschen, ey das wird zu doof, ich zieh jetzt die tastatur
wieder ab, der cpu lüfter hat geknackst, so also wir machen das jetzt anders, so ich
hab jetzt das tastatur wieder dran, also was, ok moment wir müssen jetzt erstmal die anleitung
angucken, die jemand gepostet hat, im chat, ich hab das noch nie gemacht, nein nicht lüfter
der hat dieser kühlblock halt, hallo ich kann nicht copypasten mehr, ahja das geht jetzt
oder wie, moment ich kann hierhin copypasten aber in meiner vm kann ich, ich setz das copypasten
in die vm kaputt oder wie, cack triple u, ich fass das nicht, ey das paste in die vm
ist kaputt, wtf, na gut dann gucken wir uns die anleitung mal kurz hier an, aber wir müssen
die gleich rüber kopieren, warum ist das copypasten, das copypasten in die vm ist kaputt, das will
ich nicht, das hat keinen bock mitzumachen, das kooperiert heute nicht so wirklich, also
tutorial install, install, install, boss das sieht ja voll kompliziert aus, also hier
da usb drive fit, usb drive pit, alles klar das kriegen wir raus, das kriegen wir raus,
der bootet immer noch, gut wir machen das erstmal auf fullscreen und hoffen das ich
wieder copypasten kann, seriennummer muss ich noch generieren ja, ah jetzt sehr gut,
ok tutorial, how to install, warum machen die das alles mit windows, download xpnology
both image and dsm software, ok backup, wer braucht denn sowas schon, das ist ja mal komplett
overrated, ok wo kriegt man den kram denn runtergeladen, what the fuck, da muss es doch
eine einfache anleitung geben, ok download xpnology, boot image and dsm software, unpack
to files, but download disk image, das brauchen wir alles net, wir suchen uns einfach mal
nach etcher wie man das mit linux macht, ich mach das doch net mit windows, ok also das
boot image müssen wir runterladen, ahja exquisite anleitung, dann gucken wir hier erstmal, download,
es ist von 2016, moment tutorials, install, install, install, what the fuck, wo kriegt
es eine anleitung von 2016, ok das ist big brainiger als ich mir das vorgestellt hab,
ich gucke mir jetzt irgendein tutorial video an, how to install, ah excellent, also was
der typ erzählt interessiert mich nicht, einfach nur wissen was der macht, alter was ist denn,
gibt es da keine gescheite anleitung für, monkeys, was ist mit den leuten los, ah hier
kann man die sachen runterladen, ja aber es muss doch irgendwo eine sinnvolle anleitung
geben, also muss man doch dieses tutorial hier vernehmen, ok, ah das ist ein neues tutorial,
ok if you, boah können die nicht alle mal tutorial schreiben wo man lesen kann, also
was muss ich downloaden, jo habe ich, habe ich, ja ja habe ich, habe ich, ok das muss
ich downloaden ok, ah excellent, lohnt es sich wirklich, ich hab keine ahnung ich will
aber nur ausprobieren, ok das ist echt komplizierter als ich mir das vorgestellt hab, moment ich
hab doch da vorher so eine anleitung auf deutsch gehabt, die war doch gar nicht so schlecht,
ne nicht das, das da, die anleitung war doch gar nicht so schlecht, außer dass die alles
mit windows gemacht haben, also zeig mal, bootfähiger usb stick, zeileneditor, ok das betriebssystem
dsm 617, direct download, ok bam, das kommt direkt von zynology, das kann ja schlecht
illegal sein, zack save, hat das jetzt gespeichert, so, ein text, wie siehts eigentlich mit unserem
linux, hoh leute das live image hat gebootet, poggers, aber wahrscheinlich brauchen wir
das gar nicht, ein text editor der linux zeileneditor, das haben wir alles, bootloader, das da, das
wird mega nz, das klingt ja äußerst vertrauensweckend, erstmal den grab von mega runterladen, dazu
eine sekunde leute, stopp, stopp, stopp, moment, das allerwichtigste, load, load, load, load,
mega upload gibt es schon gar nicht mehr, mega gehört ihm aber auch nicht mehr, ich
finde das ist so, das ist schon richtig, es ist eigentlich schlecht, aber es ist dadurch
schon richtig gut, upload, mega upload jawoll, nee mega gehört ihm auch nicht mehr, ok genug
weiter, soll ich wirklich sowas uraltes installieren, es muss doch ein gutes tutorial geben, es muss
doch ein gutes tutorial, wieso nennts das reddit, reddit tutorial, excellent, so, da
gibt es auch bestimmt gute installanleitungen, tut, install, ja mega gehört jetzt in der
chinesischen firma, da geht ja bestimmt ein install guide, help with install, excellent,
von ks, oh Gott die joshi musik die ist so schlimm, ja aber ich will den halbwegs aktuellen
bootloader, das hier ist ja richtig uralt was die da am start haben, wenn ich das hier
runter lade, aha reddit, excellent, xpnology club download, wie monka toss ist das alles
was wir hier machen eigentlich, ist das monka toss oder ist das erlaubt, ahja guck mal hier,
ds8615xs, was ist denn der unterschied zwischen dem zeug, du hast echt, zeig mal, up to date
oder gibts hier, so also, das ist i3wm ist das, also ich weiß überhaupt nicht was der
unterschied dazwischen ist, was nimmt man da von das da, das sieht am neuesten aus,
wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal das da, download, mega, was, nein, ah, ich will doch keine counter
stellen, fuck, aha, nee das ist was anderes, einfach mal das faq, welches faq, es gibt
ja hier 30milliarden faqs, start hier, ok ich hab nix gesagt, installation faq, where
can i download the bootloader, ok, ok, faq, big brain, die faq lesen, wir lesen die faq,
also, so ich muss jetzt alle, ja aber xrwerker, ich muss da noch irgendwo das eigentliche
betriebssystem runterladen oder, wer kann da, ok bootloader hab ich schon geladen, das
haben wir ja grad schon runtergeladen, so und dann sollten seinology download, das, das
heißt ich suche mir jetzt einfach hier das ding raus und jetzt lad ich das runter oder
das wars dann oder wie, ok wenn das jetzt echt alles ist, dann ist das wirklich einfach,
ok, installation faq, wie gehts weiter, is there any tutorial on how to install upgrade,
ja das, aber das ist 6.1, das ist ja, ja tutorial install 6.2, alter mein hirn explodiert, was
wollen, was wollen die alle von mir, da ändert sich nix, ok, ich mach das jetzt was der airworker
sagt, der kennt sich aus, jetzt ok, jetzt muss ich erstmal die fit und die pit von meinem
usb stick raussuchen, das kriegen wir recht einfach gebacken, connect to machine poggers,
ah, haben wir gemacht, demask, ah nee, ja ist ja gut, demask, ok das ding ist erkannt,
nein windows, ls usb minus was weiß ich v, bonkers, ich kann mir das immer nicht merken,
das ist linux pit fit usb, guck mal da gibt es sogar schon anleitung für, ls usb so schlau
war ich auch schon, wat, minus v, ja minus v habe ich auch schon ausgespürt, das haut
mich aber komplett voll, also warte mal mein usb stick ist das hier, das muss ich mir jetzt
mal speichern, ls minus v mal less, so, hier vendor id, product id, exquisite, das brauchen
wir, das kann ich mal gleich mal speichern, so das brauchen wir gleich um uns irgendwelche
seriennummer zu generieren, sehr gut, so das wichtigste haben wir schonmal, oder was heißt
das wichtigste als der einfachste dinger, so wie kriege ich denn den kram jetzt, ich
habe ja beides jetzt hier, ich habe jetzt ja hier das sinology boot und das dsm pad,
wie kriegt man das jetzt, kriegt man das mit etcher auf den usb stick oder wie macht man
das jetzt, einfach mit etcher drauf etchern, oder wie funktioniert das, seno boot entzippen
und hieso auf den usb ballern, ok, das ist ja mal gut das wir im chat einen haben der
schon gemacht hat, ah guck mal da ist ein image bei, exzellent, also einmal etcher, flash
vom file, jawoll, image, seno boot image, select target, jawoll 8g usb stick, beste flash,
ah geht doch, ich mein es ist ein uralt usb stick, aber busy was, es ist nicht der allerletzte
schrott usb stick, ok, so jetzt haben wir das ganze geflashed, so jetzt haben wir hier
den, was hatten wir noch alles entpackt, was hatten wir noch alles, ah da ist so ein images
ansonsten ist da gar nix drin, ok dann mounten wir das ganze jetzt, mount def stb, ja, stb2
müssen wir mounten, stb2 auf mnt, aber wenn man das richtig schreibt dann geht das auch,
da gibt es jetzt ein paar images, was muss man da jetzt bearbeiten, ruft etcher die
idee auf, ich vermute mal unter der haube schon, ja, so also ich bin grad echt verwirrt
wo was hier ist, das haben wir gemacht, ja kvm ist auch ok, ich will einfach nur wissen
was ich machen muss, ja ja das ist egal, ich überspringen die bilder, weil die brauchen
nicht, muss wissen was ich editieren muss, ist nicht reactos, ne, how to install, ja
proxmox allerdings auch ok, ich brauche, gibt es da nicht ne anleitung, crop directory,
da ist kein crop directory, oder hab ich das falsche gemountet, wenn ich nämlich, vielleicht
muss ich nämlich doch das efi ding mounten, ah hier ist group, group ist am start, so
group cfg, so exellent, so und da trägt man jetzt die fit und die pit ein, vendo, also
sprich da trage ich jetzt 1.0.x.8.5.6.4 und da machen wir jetzt 0.1.0.0, ok die haben
eine gute vendo id, so muss ich sonst noch irgendwas machen, ich hab immer noch kein
gutes tutorial gefunden, ach guck mal jetzt muss ich, jetzt muss ich irgendwelche, irgendwelche
dinger generieren, irgendwelche keys generieren, jetzt muss ich irgendwelche keys generieren,
ich hab irgendwas auf github gesehen, warte mal, ja airworker das mach ich gleich, aber
ich hab auf github irgendwas gesehen, guck mal ob der auch geht, genau, das sieht halt
schon richtig monka tos aus das ding, oh guck mal, ds 19, was hab ich nochmal ausgewählt,
ds, ach du kacke, was hab ich nochmal ausgewählt für ne, ds 19.18, ja ist das jetzt
egal oder muss ich, ich nehm mal das vom airworker, das sieht exquisite monka tos aus, was ich
hier mache grad, reference sn, ok paste generated change mac adress for your network card, what
the hell, ne ich muss jetzt die mac adresse von, von meiner, von meinem board nehmen oder,
was muss ich denn da jetzt machen, sn, das heißt ich muss mir erstmal die mac adresse
von meinem board raussuchen oder, ok das können wir ja machen, können wir uns hier drüber,
hier drüber jetzt da gleich mal holen, so wir tippen uns jetzt mal, oder mach ich das
richtig airworker, also ich suche mir jetzt die mac adresse raus, also soll ich mir jetzt
die mac, muss ich mir jetzt die mac adresse raussuchen von meiner, von meiner vm, ok was
im js viertel war ne erklärung, ne da steht nix, ich muss jetzt erstmal die mac adresse
von dem ding runter kopieren, da muss ich erst die tastatur wieder umstöpseln, und chat,
chat ihr müsst jetzt aufpassen, chat mitschreiben, ja chat muss jetzt aufpassen, weil ich kann
jetzt selbst, what the hell, ich kann jetzt selbst nicht tippen, terminal, ok mein wing,
ich brauchs ja nur für die ip, nur für die, nur für die mac, also meine mac, also e0d5-5e9fdddf,
ip leak, ja jetzt zählt es wieder gleich, der chat hat es schon wieder eingehackt son,
ich weiß, ich weiß, ich schreibs mir nochmal selbst ab, excellent, ich kopier das mal rüber,
exquisite chat, lordpad, so zeig ich mal her, nochmal kurz überprüfen das ganze, e0d5-5e9fdddf,
alles klar, gut, dann machen wir jetzt die mac rein, was, ok, und jetzt nehme ich diese
seriennummer, ist die reference sn, macht die irgendwas aus, muss ich die noch irgendwie
ändern, oder kann das so bleiben, ok, so, und das tragen wir jetzt da ein oder wie,
kurz, mac, ah die mac muss ich da auch nochmal eintragen, also sprich nochmal das hier, ja
fast, ist das juggling, das ob ich so eintrage oder so eintrage, ohne doppelpunkte, das würde
ich da auch in den chat machen, ok, das heißt, so passt das jetzt, das wars, kann sputen,
ich hab aber noch, aber ich hab mit dem offiziellen image noch gar nichts gemacht, das muss ich
da auch noch reinkopieren, oder, das pad-file, das hab ich noch nirgendswo hin kopiert, was
mach ich mit dem, ich hab hier noch, ich hab hier noch, das kommt übers webinterface, ach
so, ah, ok, dann muss ich erstmal unmounten, unmount, so, hab ich das jetzt weg, alles
klar, ja gut, dann probieren wir das mal, dann würd ich sagen, ich stöpsel mal den
usb stick dran und wir probieren das aus, das wird im leben nicht funktionieren, ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert, aber wir probieren das aus, ach so, muss ich
die tastatur wieder umstöpseln, ich seh nix, ah, exellent, ok, das heißt, im endeffekt,
jetzt wird gerebootet, ich mach mal die maus weg, jetzt wird gerebootet und dann gehen wir
ins bios und booten von usb, seh nix, ha, wow, was will der von mir, was will der von mir,
open findsynology.com, findsynology, ok, da hätt ich die tastatur noch nicht umstöpseln
müssen, wtf, woher weiß der, woher weiß ne externe seite mein nass, es geht um das
findertool, ja, aber wenn ich euch das zeige, ist das so ne gute idee, findsynology.com,
alles dauernd entstanden, schon 12 monate, exquisite, ah, das könnte an der vm liegen,
das könnte an der vm liegen, pausechamp, pausechamp, und gehts jetzt, ich guck mal
mein router, was das ding, kann ich nicht einfach in meinem dhcp gucken, ha, easy, so einfach
kanns sein, connect, next, continue, achso, hätt ich doch einfach auch im browser gucken
können, ich hätt doch einfach auch im browser gucken können, no harddisk found, please
install harddisk before reconnecting, ja, geht das usb, geht das usb, oder muss das
ne sata disk sein, geht kein usb, ok das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal nen sata kabel suchen
oder wie, ok, ich such ne sata kabel, was ssd geht, was, moment, chat ihr verwirrt mich,
also ne ssd geht, aber das muss ne sata ssd sein, oder wie, ok, moment, ich hab ja alles
da, ich muss es nur finden, wir haben ein problem, wir haben ein problem, ich zeig euch
mal was, pass mal auf, fällt euch da was auf, fällt euch da was auf, ok, wo krieg ich
den usb, das usb kabel lag nämlich hier so schön obendrauf, ich muss jetzt erstmal nen
usb kabel suchen, ne was glaube ich, einen sata kabel suchen, gucken ob ich hier noch
irgendwo im schreibtisch vielleicht ein sata kabel liegen hab, ne das sata kabel geht nicht,
das ist komplett im arsch, sieht ein bisschen kaputt aus, ok wo krieg ich jetzt ein sata
kabel her, moment, moment, da muss ich jetzt erstmal an meinen vorrat hier und vor allem
vorher muss ich mein headset entwirren, nehm noch nen sata aus der 4he kiste, das geht
nicht, das ist ein sas zu sata, doch doch ich hab garantiert jede menge sata, ich muss
mal plus finden, warte mal, wo hab ich nen sata kabel,
wir durchsuchen jetzt mal hier live die kiste, also was haben wir hier, aha, 2 alte 32, hier
sind 2 alte, moment, 32, alter was mit meinem kabel los, 32 tsasd, da kann die sata kabel
nicht weit sein, ha ich habs, chat, dazu kann man nur sagen, so next, ok, wo ist die
tsasd hier, so ich schließ mal kurz an, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ranges пл fret
so
exquisite so wir haben es
connect again hat es jetzt erkannt schauen wir mal was warum nicht
ribut gut das heißt ribut ist einfach ich mache einfach das netzteil aus
automatisch anschalten wieder funktions
und sputet nein doch ja was denn jetzt
what the hell ich dachte es wäre der lüfter alter habt ihr es auch gerade gehört
hat es auch gerade gehört im hintergrund postchamp postchamp postchamp
ich habe immer noch das gefühl hat nicht richtig geladen
da sind wir set up ganz ehrlich wenn man weiß wie es geht ist es total einfach
diese anleitung die bräuchte normalerweise fünf schritte und nicht so eine wall of text wie sie
hier teilweise fabrizieren so install latest for new features and security fixes mache ich
jetzt manual install oder sage ich install now und dann gebe ich hier das pad file an
das da
und jetzt install now das ist jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen unschlüssig
die brittes richtige postchamp musik
wenn das mit der seriennummer und so nicht funktioniert hätte hätte
der das dann jetzt schon gemeckert oder meckert er jetzt erst mit der seriennummer falls es falsch
ist welches mainboard moment das da
restarting your diskstation also wirklich was restarten tut er kann es auch doch
ok ok das der ich glaube mal der erkennt automatisch dass die neu gestartet wurde
denke nicht dass ich das noch mal wir gehen mal kurz im zweiten fenster drauf wie lang braucht
er so zum booten das hatte noch nicht großartig interessiert mal kurz in
mein dhcp der hat gerade eben sich die ip geholt der getter das system ready
warum sind die anleitung eigentlich so kompliziert geschrieben das ist doch
jetzt wirklich also immer ernsthaft gewesen einfach fünf schritte anleitung gemacht und
gut ist
und man hat gebadet der fang wieder von vorne an das ist ja microsoft taktik durchsand huge
massive debate du denkst auf einmal es geht los und es geht gar nicht los die musik ist
passiert was
geservernahme das ist nix was der irgendwie automatisch extern zugänglich macht oder
usernamen ich max passwort nein das will ich nicht passwort brauche
irgendwas das bei überlegen was ihr mit passwort
normal würde ich 1 2 3 4 5 6 nehmen aber ich weiß nicht ob der das nicht irgendwie
automatisch irgendwie von außen zugänglich macht also
passwort
ich will gar kein zynologie gehe weg
deswegen mach ich das
smart update got it device analytics nein das ist ja easy
das ist ja wirklich einfach und man muss sagen das ui fühlt sich auch
ziemlich ziemlich zackig an
kann man das irgendwie in einem docker container oder so laufen lassen
das probieren wir gleich noch mal aus das probieren wir gleich noch mal aus
ok also package ich hab zwar schon mal vor so einem zynology nass gesessen aber so wirklich
großartig gemacht habe ich da noch nix was kann man da so alles treiben
ja wir machen docker ja moment meinst du jetzt docker hier drauf oder das ding in docker
installieren wir machen einfach beides
erstmal gucken was man hier alles installieren kann
ist das euer ernst
doch so
das heißt man kann sogar ein desktop drauf installieren
kann man auch xfce oder so drauf machen nee warum kann man da
interessant ok wir machen jetzt erstmal docker
wisst ihr was dies ui
ich hab ja alles ich hab ja moment ich hab jetzt nur die system ssd dran
braucht da bestimmt noch mehr oder auf die system ssd kann ich bestimmt nix machen
oder doch
volume quick
was was zum geier ist shr das ist quasi so ein so ein pfeil oder wie
ich glaube das war chrono triggermusik
moment moment da ist doch das system drauf das kann ich doch jetzt gar nicht nehmen
da mach ich doch kaputt doch das kann man nehmen
ich glaube es euch jetzt chat ne x4 weil wir können aber btfs machen
die next critical information jetzt ist das system weg
was ist jetzt ja anscheinend wisst ihr was wofür das richtig nice ist
wenn man das selbst in einem docker container laufen lassen kann dann hat man recht ordentliches
gui wenn man einfach ein paar samba shares oder so anlegen will weil samba config ist
cancer ok jetzt aber install ich wisst ihr was das
ui für das ich meine das ist komplett im browser und das ist das ist schon noch im
browser inner vm das fühlt sich wirklich sehr responsiv und und zackig an ne guckt
euch das mal an also das fühlt sich wirklich schnell an also sie wissen was sie machen
das ist wirklich ordentlich ok open
ok der chat der chat klärt uns gerade auf was die w schreibt shr ist deren eigenes
rate system im gegenteil zu rate 5 als beispiel lassen sich auch größere platten hinzufügen
und der nutzbare speicher quasi vergrößert auch bei existentem rate lässt sich dessen
größe quasi hey das ist ja ein richtig cooles ui für den docker kram es gibt auch community
packages ok das erscheint mir ziemlich nice ok wir machen jetzt den who am i das ist dieser
hallo weltcontainer den zählen wir jetzt mal choose tags layer latest select
mach mal bitte oben rechts die kamera weg da oben also ich kann mal oben rechts aber
du siehst oben rechts nix guck da ist nix besonderes oben rechts das ist ein usermenü
ok und wo steht jetzt mich den erreichen kann ach launch
jetzt hat das jetzt hat das runtergeladen ok ach ne da hat es das image erst runtergeladen
ok so und jetzt launch container name lull das ui ist gut das ui ist viel besser als
den hier offizielles ui man kann sogar ein shortcut hier voll auf dem stoff der startseite
von denen machen status page network ports ich lasse das mal weg mal gucken was man hier
machen kann next container port 80 local port mal gucken was er da auswählt
ok wo sehe ich jetzt was da wie wo läuft hier local port steht es doch
also quasi gehe ich jetzt mal hier auf port 32768 und dann läuft mein container drauf
das ist das ist echt nice gemacht das finde ich echt gut das ist ja ungefähr dreimal
besser als irgendwelche auf media volt oder oder finas oder sonst was das ist das ist
echt cool gemacht das gefällt mir ziemlich gut support center hallo ich habe eure sache
nicht gekauft aber helft mir so und wie komme ich jetzt ach guck mal das ist wirklich easy
gemacht das finde ich echt gut ach stimmt ein terminal an die tippen kam also da brauche
ich ein addon ok ja aber das ist nice guck mal allein schon dass ich hier ziemlich gutes
docker ui habe finde ich gut ich mein bringen tut es mir nix ich würde ja wenn schon das
im docker container laufen lassen probieren wir übrigens jetzt gleich noch mal aus habe
ich den docker das probiere ich ja gleich mal drauf aus ob man das selbst im docker laufen
lassen kann oracle linux meine güte gehts mir fort ok was können wir sonst noch schönes
machen schon mal mitlehrprogramm ich nicht da kann man irgendwie to factor identifizierung
oder sowas machen was passiert denn moment das muss ich jetzt mal ausbauen container
man konnte irgendwie advanced edit wie kommt man jetzt in die advanced stopp kommt man noch
kommt man noch mal in die advanced settings oder geht das wirklich nur beim anlegen ach
hier create shortcut und desktop status page ah moment das ist das hier das bringt es mir
jetzt net aber ich könnte sagen du bist nur für verknüpfung meisters glaube ich ganz
praktisch web page und dann irgendwie ja was war es denn drei weil das eigentlich immer
random ist start ok das ist random der port fast naja gut kann man es auch hier wieder
löschen aber man kann den port mit sicherheit fest vergeben ja aktuell macht er den port
automatisch aber man kann bestimmt den port noch einstellen ja port settings ja einfach
den da jetzt hat er immer den exzellent zack das ist cool man kann sich gar nicht verknüpfung
drauf speichern also stocker ui das finde ich finde ich deutlich besser als das offizielle
docker ui und nicht so und nicht so konfus wie das hier ich weiß das ist nicht das offizielle
aber das benutzen viele ich finde das ultra konfus dann mache ich lieber die sachen über
die kommando zeite weiß ich bin ich der einzige der eben dazu geht dass er das übelst konfus
findet diese portainer geschichte dann mache ich mir lieber in docker container feil in
den docker compose feil oder lebe mache ich mit docker containers von hand so offiziell
image also in kuba nades für daheim habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht dran gedacht
mit einem host und drunter da ist wie man docker compose feil einfach ins repo eingecheckt
sogar lieber ok nice was will der hier system event exzellent so was haben wir hier noch
für packages zeig mal hier was haben wir noch für packages borg backup irgendjemand
auch vorhin gesagt es gibt community packages community packages gibt es denn da was syno
community aha und da gibt es dann borg backup und sonst was ah exzellent shell z shell
stimmt was sagt er mir starr mich wenn ich nach shell suche not found ok also shell gibt
es standardmäßig anscheinend nicht betta betta versions erläuterte kontakt note station
wetten dass die notiz app besser ist als die von nex cloud weil die von nex cloud ist
so dermaßen schlecht
search da kann man auch sein nass ordentlich durchsuchen ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich
cool
ernsthaft ich überlege echt gerade weil die sache ist die ich will nex cloud schon eine
ganze weile weg haben einfach weil mir nex cloud nicht gefällt und ich das meiste von
nex cloud nicht verwende und die dinger die sie nex cloud gibt total unfertig sind zum
größten teil so und ich brauche also einen calder server und ich brauche einen file
server ich bin mir grad ernsthaft am überlegen deswegen probieren wir gleich die docker install
ich bin ernsthaft im überlegen das wirklich zu verwenden nicht unbedingt auf der hardware
die da oben jetzt eingeblendet soll ich die hardware übrigens eingeblendet lassen oder
ausgeblendet dass wir machen damit ja nix mehr allerdings man muss es also man verpasst
oben rechts auch nix da ist auch nix oben rechts
das sieht das sieht wisst ihr was wir machen wir machen es einfach einen ticken kleiner
ups excellent machen sie einfach ein bisschen kleiner weil dann verpasst man wirklich nix
also da oben ist jetzt jetzt verpasst du nur wirklich gar nix mehr da oben so notes haben
wir installiert zeig mal her guck mal der zeigt dir sogar die neuen sachen an das ist
mal wirklich ordentliche ui geschichte was die hier gemacht haben nicht so wie sie das
bei nextcloud gemacht haben note station was yes alles klar was auch immer das getrieben
hat web klipper sonst was desktop version gibt es ja auch für linux oder auch nicht
note station gibt es note station note station für linux was sind die specks hier guck mal
das ist das bord das ist aber müll das würde ich dafür nicht verwenden das ist nur so
ein testbord das ist das bord das ist ein dual core zeleron ding das tolle software
version download wo kann man note station downloaden achso muss ich jetzt mal sagen
dass guckt mal das gibt sogar für linux was ist denn mit denen los das hätte ich jetzt
nicht gedacht gibt es note station das ist ja cool welche sport ich empfohlen hatte
für mein nass das da ne warte mal srock das moment oh guck mal die haben was neues aber
ich hab das hier das da also jetzt nicht hier das was hier oben rechts ist ein anderes das
von meinem wo die anderen sachen bei mir drauf laufen das oben rechts ist ja nur das test
bord für heute so das probier ich jetzt echt mal aus ob man hier note station ob man das
installiert bekommt das ist ja wirklich nice gemacht er öffnet ja ganz neue möglichkeiten
hier aber was ist für gedudelt das ist breath of the wild soundtrack oder dass das hört
sich so gedudelt an an eke es ist pigment passt leider leider ist das soundtrack an
breath of the wild das mit abstand schwächste finde ich ich weiß viele sagen ja das passt
zur atmosphäre dass das hauptsächlich klaviergespiele gibt custom repo das machen wir jetzt auch
noch custom repo aber ich installiere es bei note station so custom repo musste man du
meinst das custom repo hier erst mal warten bis der hier die note station installiert
hat so jetzt mal eine ganz blöde frage warum genau sollte ich mir jetzt in sinology nass
kaufen dann wenn das doch nicht mal monka tos ist so viel besser wenn ich das auf meiner
eigenen kiste laufen lassen kann ich mein klar wenn ich keinen bock habe in der eigenen
kiste hinzustellen ist es ja vollkommen in ordnung aber so ist doch viel besser also
zumindest für mich ist monka test tos weil es schöner ist als das oben rechts ja das
oben rechts ist ja nur das testbord also weniger als das bord glaube ich nicht also die bords
brauchen irgendwie 6 7 watt eidel hallo was macht er da let's go ich installiere schon
mal das custom repo mittlerweile also was soll ich machen log in to your nass go to main
menu package center settings ok das ist guck mal man findet sich total zurecht so muss
so muss den ui aussehen package sources add cyno community zack bäm das ist das ist einfach
intuitiv und gut machbar exzellent community zack total einfach kann man das selbst gebaute
mit einer signology box verbinden kein schimmer ich habe das heute zum ersten mal installiert
jetzt haben wir sogar ein desktop client dafür cyno
moment was habe ich für ein ip das da das username max password
das ist doch mal easy zack haben wir noch gar noch eine tweets app die auch ganz gut
funktioniert das ist bestimmt elektronen app oder chat was meint ihr ist es eine elektronen
app das eine elektronen app
ist wie not found what the fuck
moment wo speichert er diese dinger mal gucken was das ist
ja ja ja das ist das ist das ist package denn das ist kein elektron das ist ein dings
wie heißt wie heißt diese elektronen wie das ist die elektronen wgs genau das ist
die konkurrenz aber es ist es ist es ist es quasi eine elektronen anwendung sowas ähnliches
sowas ähnliches kann man auch ganz einfach chesten wie viel ram brauchst wie viel wie
viel ram brauchst
einfach testen wie viel rams brauche signology ja da da ist es was versuchen f3 es braucht
einfach 150 mb ram easy gut so geht sogar noch das ist sogar noch ganz brauchbar ok
interessant also oder to do lists sind die to do lists kalder oder ist das was ist das
finde ich gut gemacht gefällt mir hat was so was kann man sonst noch alles installieren
das kommt gibt es ist zum werbefiltern was big book was
auch wurde ja oft down gelaudet kann man die sachen hier irgendwie sortieren nach beliebtheit
oder so oder geht das nur hier wir gucken jetzt wir gehen jetzt mal shell ein was was
wenn da haben set shell install kriegen wir sogar eine shell da drauf das doch ganz gut
ich muss trusten ah package sources ok wie truste ich hier was
ah hier ah jetzt funktioniert es ja sehr nice
kann ich das jetzt hier drüber öffnen wie starte ich das jetzt
wie starte ich das denn jetzt ssh so ne das geht schon mal nett welchen port ok warte
mal ssh muss ich vor muss ich irgendwie ssh erst installieren du musst den ssh service
erst enable control panel advanced modus habe ich fast schon gedacht und jetzt aber dazu
hätte ich auch gar nicht der hätte ich erst gar nicht ssh installieren müssen excel ach
so moment ach doch max passt und jetzt hier ja nice
jetzt kann ich sagen cool ist hier standard ne bash eigentlich ne bash kann man auch starten
nice sogar noch mit ssh access excellent so aber guck mal die mega cli
ok es gibt echt viel zur auswahl es gibt wirklich viel zur auswahl wir gehen mal kurz
bei das sind die offiziellen packages hier ne wir gehen noch mal ganz schnell kurz gucken
ne das ist third party hier also wir gehen ja mal ganz kurz kurz ok das ist mir ziemlich
wurscht anti virus essentials juckt mich auch nicht cloud station server juckt mich essential
management juckt mich auch nicht karta server könnte interessant sein wenn ich nextcloud
wegschmeißen in dns server brauche ich nicht mich interessiert wie die verwaltung für
dns server ist das interessiert mich da haben die dhcp wäre interessant wie da die verwaltung
ist so open auch sogar ein ganz praktisches que hier für dns zeug das braucht man nicht
aber die die oberflächen finde ich wirklich ganz ganz nützlich wie sie das gemacht haben
installieren wir da jetzt kein anti virus leute ok das geht nicht wenn ich keinen account
habe kann ich denn kann ich denn nen offiziellen zynology account mit so einem mit so einem
fake zynology machen das geht wegen der seriennummer nicht ok also sprich manche sachen gehen
wirklich nur mit einem offiziellen zynology wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe
hyper gachi vault surveillance station ach nee geht gar nicht ich kann keine surveillance
station hinzufügen weil ich will ja meine passwörter von den webcams nicht leaken aber
man kann auch bestimmt was enable run after installation ok ich füge einfach mal ein
test stream hinzu big bug bunny rtsp stream fügen wir da jetzt hinzu ich meine ich muss
den webcam faken 24 stunden stream wozu von 24 stunden stream hat doch keiner was was
bringt den stream wo ich nach 6 7 stunden im arsch bin und nur noch im halbschlaf hier
durch den striemen strieme macht doch auch keinen sinn moin deadlift ntp must be enabled
ja ja mach da ist die surveillance station google chrome naja im firefox wirds auch gehen
ok erst mal eine kamera hinzufügen add quick setup ip test be invalid format achso
ok das ist komplizierter als ich das gedacht habe
please select brand gibt es nicht so was wie generic user define ah
das funktioniert wirklich erstaunlich gut das zeug hier muss ich echt sagen also das
hätte ich nicht das hätte ich echt nicht gedacht kann man den dsm 7 schon installiert
was ist was ist denn der dsm 7 disk station manager oder sowas wahrscheinlich ok gucken
wir uns mal die kamera an da ist einfach einfach die kamera tut einfach wenn ok das ist also
chat ich weiß es hätten einige vielleicht nicht gemerkt aber das ist keine echte webcam
das ding kann ja extrem viel zeug ach guck mal der hat sogar hier die photos auf hat das
irgendeine ordentliche übersicht wo man wo man die live wo man die views so nebeneinander
machen kann hat das sowas würdest du das einsetzen nee ich behalte mein selbstprogrammiertes
ding weil mein selbstprogrammiertes kamera übersichts ding geht über web rtc das hat
quasi keine verzögerung das hier wird ein bisschen verzögerung haben und meins funktioniert
halt auch wunderbar auf dem tablet und so ich weiß nicht wie das hier aussieht weil
zum beispiel was ich hier nicht checke ist wie kann man sich hier anzeigen lassen einfach
alle camps nebeneinander das geht wahrscheinlich nicht zeigt mal den source zeigt den source
net da steht die passwörter von kameras drin wobei die steht in der konfig datei drinne
wir haben wir haben das doch sogar im stream hier mal zusammen gebastelt und ich hab doch
sogar mal so eine so eine beta version davon raus raus gehauen wollte die weiter programmieren
was ich aber nie gemacht habe und ihr kennt mich ja und mittlerweile habe ich schon umgewusst
also gut mehr kann man hier anscheinend nicht machen da gefällt mir meins aber echt besser
aber wenn wenn wenn das hier die einzige übersicht hier ist die man von den kameras hat dann
ist das nicht so schön für den desktop den desktop brauche ich nicht ich brauche irgendwas
was im browser läuft unter anderem auf tablets du musst mehr kameras anlegen um sie sehen
zu können ja aber ich habe doch eine kamera ich will einfach nur eine vorschau sehen hier
das funktioniert anscheinend nicht vorschau geht nur in diesem diesem review ding
ich habe bis jetzt nur eine ja gut ich meine ich kann natürlich da mal mehrere sachen hinzufügen
machen wir einfach haben wir einfach den gleichen stream noch mal rein complete setup user define
kameratest fail o grip mehr als eine connection gleichzeitig darf ich nicht aufbauen na gut
es gibt eine was slash camp ich habe rtsp doppelt application center alter das ding
kann er 30 milliarden sachen da blinkt auch boah ach guck mal hier live view ds camp live
camp live view multicast run nähe das was anderes visual station kann man da alles
machen zu youtube nein ich will meine privaten kameras nicht zu youtube streben
live view auf nen ich will ja nicht den live view auf dem desktop was im browser hat er
ach so live view also also meinst du ich brauche sowas hier also sprich in dem package ist
hier live ne gibt hier live view
ich weiß nicht was du meinst also hier gibt es kein live viewer pdf viewer on a so violent
station alter wie viel zeug what the fuck ach hier ah guck mal da kann man sogar die
kameras steuern ich würde jetzt nur mal interessieren über was die das ganze verteilen moment
da müssen wir mal die die developer tools aufmachen so ist es ist das live streaming
was ist das was ist das schwer zu sagen das ist hts oder das ist hts streaming würde
ich sagen oder was ist das xml ne das ist was anderes das ist nicht der video stream
geht keine ahnung was das geht ist das websocket geschichten ich weiß es nicht was über was
der stream geht aber was das für eine ist man kann leider die verzögern hier nicht
richtig testen jetzt in so einem test stream nee aber krass zeug also was die da alles
dabei haben ist echt wahnsinnig es ist wahnsinnig ist echt heftig so ich will also mal kurz
gucken was wir noch für packages haben directory server das ist für die leute keine hd voll
oder wie media server webtaf server okay das sind jetzt die sachen aus dem nee das sind
immer noch die offiziellen packages was gibt es denn aus dem community kops das braucht
keiner h top aber ich meine das sind kommando zeilen top mein borg kenne ich borg habe
ich selbst im einsatz zu backupen das muss ich nicht drauf drauf packen hat es den haumas
dann installieren kann irgendwelche download geschichten kennst du dich mit hardware security
modulen aus also wir haben den juby key auf der arbeit aber das zählt ja wohl kaum nee
nicht nicht wirklich gut image magic ios access ach dann kann man quasi von seinem iphone
die dinger draufsinken oder wie sing sing in mqt mutt okay das wollen wir hier drauf
echt nicht verwenden mutt ist ein text mail client
wie wäre es mit dax der dax ist ein irc bouncer im jahr 2020 ne dax gibt es auch nicht
ne also aber ich es echt hat was die da alles dabei haben das hätte ich nicht gedacht ich
bin ernsthaft am überlegen ob ich mir das nicht nicht nicht installiere und darüber
zumindest mein fileserver gedöns und ein bisschen als kalder ersatz für nextcloud nehmen übrigens
wenn bei der gelinger das müssen wir noch ausprobieren wie macht man hier drauf jetzt
ein falscher und falscher so wie wie gebe ich das jetzt frei also die keg station die
kriegt erst mal neuen folder great new shared folder da sind wir doch schon dabei das schöne
ist dass das hier relativ intuitiv ist name lull w größer keg w description enable restrict
access to administrator ja okay kann man nicht einfach sagen für alle
next next enable data checksum ein problem alles nicht quota wer braucht den so was apply
Gast, ja so macht man es easy, so macht man es easy.
Redried, jawoll, haben alle redried, bei Gast redried reicht.
Was ist denn Preview und Group Permissions?
Ich kenne User und Group, aber was ist beides?
Advanced Permission, sogar NFS, MonkaS.
So jetzt hat er einen Ordner angelegt, schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert.
Ah ok, also Gast geht schon mal nicht oder muss man einfach sagen Gast?
Ok das geht nicht, aber mit meinem User geht es wahrscheinlich.
Ha, da sind wir, ah ich hätte nur auf den Ordner gedurft wahrscheinlich, ich hätte
den Ordner gleich eingeben müssen, dann hätte es wahrscheinlich auch ohne User funktioniert.
Wisst ihr was ich bis heute nicht gecheckt habe, wie man sich unter Windows abmeldet.
Wie meldet man sich ab von einem Network Share, dass er jetzt nicht weiterhin den
gleichen Username verwendet.
Ok kann ich auch Zeug, gar nicht, Passwort ändern, big brain.
Hier geben wir mal hier was, ich downloatze, irgendwie nur den Schuh nass, es ist also
ganz ehrlich, das ist mit Abstand bisher von den Funktionen her das beste an das Ding
die ich gesehen habe, von der Usability das beste und von der Vielfalt auch das beste.
Gut es geht auf die SSD, also da kann man echt nichts sagen und dann macht Gigabit voll,
auch mit der Kack CPU.
Echt nice, so und jetzt probieren wir mal das Zeug auch noch in docker zu installieren.
Weil ergeblich sollte es funktionieren und das wäre natürlich für meine Einsatzzwecke
auch cool.
Kann man xp0, nein das ist, so wie ich es jetzt gemacht habe, was du oben rechts in
der Ecke siehst hier, da läuft es gerade rauf, also du kannst nicht einfach auf einen schon
bestehenden Server hauen, zumindest so wie ich es gemacht habe, ich habe neu installiert,
vom USB Stick oder das Betriebssystem läuft auf dem USB Stick, so rum.
In der vm würde gehen, ja angeblich geht es im docker Container auch, was kvm virtual
installieren, was soll denn das sein, da kann ich ja auch einen kvm selbst installieren.
Wie willst du das sonst machen, einfach im Container starten und Zugriff auf Devices
geben, ist ja nicht ob das funktioniert, eine kvm vm ist klar, dass ich das machen kann,
das geht nicht, ooooh, pp hans, warum soll ich das on docker in einer kvm vm laufen lassen
warum nicht direkt auf docker auf dem host, ne das gucke ich mir, ne nextload gucke ich
mir mal einen anderen stream an, aber wir können mal gucken wie einfach sich das hier
installieren lässt, ich habe es doch eben gerade gesehen, what, ich habe es doch eben
hier noch irgendwo gesehen oder bin ich total blind, wo ist es denn, ach ne hier, ne woment,
ist das hier nett, hier nur als docker image, also quasi nur über den hier, das da, so
jetzt lädt das ja erstmal das image runter, dann muss man wahrscheinlich noch was neues
erstellen danach, aber das docker gui finde ich gut, das ist besser als den ja offizielles
gui, also das desktop docker gui gefällt mir gar nicht und ich finde es auch deutlich angenehmer
als irgendwie portena oder diese anderen dinger die es dafür gibt, latest, ne ne ne 20, merkt
euch sowas nie mit latest machen, gibt es nicht, einfach 20 schon fertig, einfach 20,
haben die ihre tags noch nicht geupdatet, kann das, oder bin ich blind, ja kann das sein
dass die ihre tags noch nicht geupdatet haben, ah stable, aber stable ist doof, ich will
den tag haben, weil so update er mir ja auch auf 21, in dem fall jetzt wurscht, guck dir
mal den virtual machine manager an, oh wir können nested virtualization machen, dann
wird es noch, ach du große neu, ok moment, das heißt hier drinnen im packages wird,
ok jetzt wird nested virtualisiert auf einer 2 core machine, excellent, ach stimmt das
ist ja gar nicht nested, wir sind ja wirklich auf echter hardware, ich bin schon ganz verwirrt,
man kann sonst immer alles auf der vm machen, aber das erste was ich gesagt habe ist richtig,
das erste ist, dass es 2 kerne sind und dafür ist es halt wahrscheinlich nicht so tolle,
so jetzt gucken wir erstmal ob er nextcloud gestartet hat, download ist complete, also
das GUI finde ich wirklich gut, das gefällt mir echt, das macht man einfach hier anlegen,
nextcloud, ah next, ach guck mal jetzt macht er hier 19.03, die haben noch nicht getaggt,
die haben noch nicht ihre docker sachen getaggt, das ist ja aber fail, wie lösche ichs wieder,
delete, haben die hier schon geupdatet, irgendwer hat bestimmt schon geupdatet und wenn sich
das offizielle image ist dann ein anderes, haben die schon geupdatet, haben die schon
geupdatet, 20 LS was soll denn das sein, egal 20 LS, was auch immer sie mir damit sagen
wollen, Leute das Cynology UI gefällt mir wirklich gut, progers, richtiger progers,
launch, next, container port, local port, kann man das auch gleich hier umstellen oder
muss man das, details, das ist aber wirklich einfach, da kannst du dich wirklich nicht
beschweren, so ich stoppe den kram mal, auf, geh aus, jetzt machen wir einmal einen festen
port, dass wir zumindest noch gucken können, ob das überhaupt funktioniert, lokaler port
443, müssen wir nicht weiter, 8000, apply, start, jetzt gehen wir hier auf zack, port
8000, moment, warum willst du mich weiterleiten auf HTTPS, nein, 8000, was, gehst du fort,
was ist das, port 8000, 8000, was willst du von mir, HTTPS, port 8000, ok, port 8000
ist nicht so gut, das funktioniert nämlich nicht, edit, ok, port 4443, vielleicht geht
das, 4443, HTTPS, ja, alles gut, Nextcloud ist kaputt, ich habe es kaputt gemacht, blöb,
Nextcloud, broken, deswegen, und eines der Gründe warum ich Nextcloud weg haben will,
weil irgendwas immer nicht funktioniert, wahrscheinlich hat er rumgespackt, jetzt weil
ich ihn ausgeschaltet habe zwischendurch, ja, es könnte ja sogar sein, advanced settings,
kann ich hier sagen, network port, ok, 4443, port 8000, 8000, machen wir halt mal so, next,
next, ok, jetzt mal schauen ob ich es jetzt aufmachen darf, noch tut sich hier gar nichts,
die cacstation, er macht dinger, er braucht ziemlich viel cpu, port 4443, ah, da sind
wir, max, 123456, jawoll, funktioniert, also dieser docker manager ist gut, plus ich will
kein nextcloud mehr haben, es muss weg, nextcloud muss ich, fort, aber es funktioniert, das
gucken wir uns aber in einem der nächsten, das kann ich mir nicht heute auch noch angucken,
das ist zu viel input auf einmal für mich, das gucken wir uns im nächsten stream an, ob
die sich oder in einem der nächsten schrieben, ob die das verbessert haben, für mich hatte
nextcloud zu viele Probleme, gerade die eingebauten apps waren so wahnsinnig unfertig, mit notizapps
die man nicht durchsuchen kann und sowas, hast du schon einen quick connect angelegt,
nö, ach du meinst das ding aufm, doch hier, hab ich schon, du meinst aufm desktop das
ding, das hab ich schon gemacht, halt für den anderen service, oder was meinst du, was
macht der da eigentlich gerade, wenn man mal fragen darf, was treibt der da, egal wir probieren
jetzt mal den vm manager aus, wirds nur machine manager, wisst ihr was ich auch ziemlich
gut finde hier in dem, dass das einheitlich aussieht, die oberfläche, dass die, dass
die ein, sag mal das ist doch der wird, das sieht aus wie der wird manager, bisschen wie
der ganz normale wird manager von linux, bloß im zynology style, oh ne, was will der jetzt
hier, check, was will der, was will der von mir, was, please select volume on which, your
virtual machine, alles klar, hat's nextcloud, oh nextcloud hat's geschafft, das ist die
neue nextcloud oberfläche, exquisite, so da probieren wir mal gleich eine sache aus,
wir probieren es doch jetzt aus, apps, ob man durchsuchen kann, achso wir müssen gucken,
das muss die 20er version sein, weil nur die 20er version hat das neue dashboard, äh
notes, notes, notes, notes app und to do, to do, äh to do sind glaub ich standardmäßig
integriert im kalender oder, ne es heißt nicht to do, es heißt tasks heißts ja, tasks heißts
ja, tasks, so, da kommt mir gleich mal die sache ob sie das verbessert haben, so gehen
wir erstmal in notes rein, new note, plupp und text, äh kann man jetzt keine überschrift
machen, hallo, cute, chat, aiaia, 1, 2, 3, golden kappa, check, so save, äh ich brauch
noch ne neue note, irgendwas, save, so und jetzt suchen, suchen, kappa, oh, die suche
funktioniert, ich bin begeistert, es springt zwar nicht an die seite, aber immerhin, man
findet schon mal wieder was, aiaiai, die suche funktioniert, stell dir mal vor, stimmt vielleicht
kanns markt dauern, oh es kann sogar markt dauern, aiaiai, man kann, das ist gut, das
ist gut, man kann jetzt endlich seine notizen durchsuchen, das ging ja früher nicht, was
eigentlich total ein fail ist, dass man 5 versionen gebrauchen hat bis man seine notizen
durchsuchen kann, kappa, moment, mal gucken wie schnell wir auf irgendwelche limitierungen
treffen, wartet mal, so wir machen das mal ein bisschen länger und jetzt schreiben wir
da irgendwas rein was, so wir haben grad 139 zusch, äh 939 zuschauer, kegwe, so und jetzt
such ich mal nach 139, äh 193, ich bin begeistert, die suche funktioniert, ich mein richtig
premium wärs jetzt natürlich noch, wenn es dort hinspringen würde wo er was findet,
aber ich mein es ist zumindest, es ist zumindest benutzbar, schnell ist es nett, aber was jetzt
natürlich doppelt doof ist, dass man jetzt nicht die browser suche verwenden kann um
da hinzuspringen, weil guck mal wenn ich hier drin bin, das mein ich halt mit so unpolished
ringer bei nextcloud, wenn ich jetzt hier drin bin und will jetzt die 139 suchen, weil
der mich nicht zur richtigen zeile bringt und ich drück wieder steuerung f, dann komm
ich nie dort an, dann komm ich immer wieder nach oben in die datei, das heißt ich muss
hier oben hin klicken, muss 193 machen, ich mein das geht, aber schön ist es nett, so
jetzt probieren wir das ganze mal mit tasks aus, ob man da jetzt was durchsuchen kann,
das ist der erste task, zweiter task ist subsgiften, dritter task ist stream ausmachen, so und jetzt
gucken wir mal ob er das auch durchsuchen kann, stream, hey, das macht das ganze sogar halbwegs
benutzbar, ich bin begeistert, kann er auch text in drinne durchsuchen, keck, w, lul, w,
blub, guck mal der findet sogar im text findet er was, ok man kann das benutzen, kann und
jetzt die wichtigste, kann die foto app pngs, die konnte nämlich das letzte mal keine pngs,
die krieg ich da jetzt am besten in png rein, kann man das dreckend droppen, ich brauch
die foto app keine pngs, das ist kein witzig, ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht, wie uploade
ich denn hier was, gar nicht, die foto app zeigt ja nur an, man muss files, hinzufügen
upload file, der keksor, so, ah, ne, die foto app kann immer noch keine pngs, oder muss
ich das in fotos verschieben, nein ich muss, muss das in fotos verschieben, weil vorher
hat er alles durchsucht, und dann konnte der keine, ne da kann immer noch keine, ne da
kann immer noch keine pngs, irgendwie kann man keine pngs anzeigen im jahr 2020, was
ist da los, ich weiß jetzt kommen die ersten Leute, die sagen max png ist aber auch kein
foto, ist mir doch wurscht, das ist bildformat, was ich da einmachen will, aber zumindest
die suche ist verbessert, ne ich habs dreck und dropp, das ist jetzt im richtigen ordner,
guckt da, fotos, wieso sollte png nicht gehen, ja weil es nicht geht, wieso weiß ich nicht,
aber ich möchte zurück, funktioniert, hike, was ist hike,
modernes bildformat, das ist eine gute frage, ob hike funktioniert, kann
man nach hike image suchen, ohne dass monka tos kommt, hab ich doch nie gehört, also wenn
png nicht funktioniert, da kannst du von ausgehen, es wird auch kein hike, ja genau, dieses,
das hatten wir das letzte mal auch gefunden, die sind immer noch am diskutieren ob pngs
fotos sind oder nicht, das ist halt so ein nachteil manchmal was open source entwicklung
angeht, die leute diskutieren sich kaputt an den simpelsten, an den simpelsten sachen,
ich mein das ist ein jahr fast schon offen das ding und die sind immer noch am drüber
labern ob png jetzt ein foto ist oder nicht, ja, oh guck mal es gibt ein publicast für
hike, moment, die haben hike gemercht aber png nicht, niemand benutzt hike images, aber
alle benutzen png
die machen mich fertig, my next lord, die machen mich fertig, naja, oh nein, ah genau
wir wollten noch die virtual machines ausprobieren, so wie machen wir virtual machines jetzt hier,
jetzt kommt big brain time, create, windows, linux, moment man kann, ich könnte eine virtual
disk station in einer disk station machen, warum denn das, disk station das ist ja mal
big brain, ja, mach da, also das ist nicht meine, das ist keine sinology, das ist ne
fake sinology hier, die keg station macht jetzt auch noch ne linux vm, auf gehts, poc
u, memory 1g, cpu 1, wunderbar, virtual disk, disk, k20g, brauchen wir eh nicht so viel,
obmw, not connected, iso file, ah, ja gut, da stellt sich mir jetzt die nächste frage,
wie krieg ich, wie krieg ich den iso hier drauf, kann man hier uploaden, upload, ahja,
ok, obuntu server iso, du du du, alter die joshi Musik, kann ich einfach downloaden, obuntu
ich will einfach downloaden, was, what, alter, ist das euer ernst obuntu, das ist ja, versteckt
er könnts ja nicht sein, ja genau, das muss man mit dem vlc öffnen, so Ubuntu iso öffn ich
sonst auch immer mit dem vlc, wer nicht, wer kennts nicht, so iso browse, ok, das heißt
ich kann das jetzt hier uploaden, das iso file, excellent, upload, was, skip, iso, da, beides
könnt man auch nehmen, upload, sieht man den progress, alter, das ist echt gut das que,
das gefällt mir, das ist wirklich pock, oh jetzt hab ich den falschen ordner geladen,
sei wurscht, select, so, was auch immer, ja, passt, weiter, ich hab access, jawoll, apply,
bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das läuft, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert,
action, power on, preparing, running, ok, wie krieg ich denn, wie krieg ich denn das,
irgendein GUI davon, doppelt anklicken vielleicht, ne, wie krieg ich da jetzt ein GUI von, ah
connect vielleicht, ah, ah, der klassische vlc viewer, guck mal wie es funktioniert
einfach nur, wie es einfach nur funktioniert, halbe proxmox, ja, aber echt, das ist der
klassische vlc viewer, das ding, erkennste sofort, genauso, genauso hier, das sieht halt
so ein bisschen 1995 aus, aber es funktioniert, aber man muss wirklich sagen, also was da
funktionsmäßig drin ist, ist echt erstaunlich, vor allem, dass das alles ein einheitliches
GUI hat, ich mein die werden wild rumgeklaut haben für die Funktionalität, aber, dass
man allein schon die Oberfläche so hinkriegt, ist wirklich nicht schlecht, also da kann
sogar ich mich nicht beschweren, private key league, bonkers, nein, hack ist raus, seid
ihr schon eingeloggt chat, ja, man kann einfach hier drin Ubuntu server installieren, nice,
progressive POG, ich bin begeistert, wie einfach das ist, das funktioniert wirklich gut,
ich weiß gar nicht, was ich da schlechtes drüber sagen soll, ok, wenn
ich was schlechtes sagen will, dann mach ich nextcloud auf, also ich bin ernsthaft am
überlegen, das einzusetzen, angeblich geht das seit der neuesten version, dass man irgendeine
matrix bridge machen kann, dann auch windows, ach das so, ich dachte das war eine frage,
ja das hab ich gelesen, dass man das machen kann in der neuen version, gut vm ist hier
drauf natürlich wirklich nicht schnell, wie kann man sich die auslastung ans, ach so,
da macht es ja schon, und wie ist die Gesamtsystemauslastung, so, oh gut, die CPUs sind am limit, pngs gehen
in der photostation app garantiert, 100 pro, 100 pro gehen ab pngs, das ist ja kein nextcloud,
obunto photostation, ops, können wir mal ausprobieren, chat ist wohl im weg, php, gut, ehrlich gesagt
juckt mich nicht auf was das läuft, so der obunto server rödelt vor sich hin, das ding
hat volle auslastung, oah 90 prozent, ey das ding hat nur 2 cpu kerne, da geht das so
flüssig geht, ist ja schon eine leistung, also ich muss euch sagen bei der software
hab ich hier so, bei der software hab ich das gefühl, dass ich das einfach gut benutzen
lässt und bei der software hab ich halt so ein bisschen das gefühl, glaub das beschreibt
es ganz gut, also das hat mich echt beeindruckt das ding, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass du
damit so viel machen kannst und es dann auch noch so ein einheitliches GUI hat, was sich
gut bedienen lässt, kommt ja die photostation auch noch, not now, ok create your first album,
twitch chat, private album, man kanns auch noch sharen und jetzt gucken wir mal ob man
da auch png hinzufügen kann, oah man kann pngs hinzufügen, ist das ganze open source,
äh ne, teilweise wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich teilweise die sachen die sie sich geklaut
haben irgendwo, oh was, moment der kann kein png, doch da ist er doch, von wegen, hast
du mal photoshop auf linux getestet, ja vor jahren hab ich das mal gemacht, das neue dazu
braucht man aber bestimmt eine gültige lizenz, deswegen kann ich das nicht ausprobieren,
weil ich keine gültige photoshop lizenz hab, ich benutze mittlerweile affinity designer,
weil das für low brains wie mich besser ist, wäre es möglich über xenology eine vm zu
betreiben, ja, guck mal da, das grad ubuntu server install über diese, über den virtual
manager von xenology, es ist nicht schnell, aber es liegt an meiner hardware, meine hardware
ist ein absolut low low low end dual core powerspare intel system, das ist der ssd hängt
da dran, ssd, du siehst da unten irgendwo glaube ich sogar noch rumhängen hier, guck
da, siehst du die ssd rumhängen, übrigens ist euch mal aufgefallen was das hier für
big brain aufsatz ist, das ist pci express auf m2, exquisite aufsatz hier, ich könnte
da noch ne pci gerade reinstecken, passivkühler klar, die cpu ist da direkt drauf, die cpu
wird mit dem board verkauft, das ist wirklich low end, die photo station geht auch, man
muss sagen, also hier ist das ganze ziemlich einheitlich gemacht vom gui, diese zusatz
apps die es dann so gibt, die sehen alle ein bisschen unterschiedlich aus, guck mal,
das wichtigste ist schon mal da, man hat ne dark seam, das allerwichtigste, nextcloud
sollte doch eigentlich gar keine großartige cpu mehr brauchen, der macht ja nix mehr,
oder, macht der noch was, wow, what the fuck, ach ne, ne guck der macht nix, der ist eidel,
da braucht der auch nicht viel, moments ist auch nice, was ist denn moments, das ist die
neue foto app, moments, ah, organize your personal photos intelligently, ok, das ist quasi die
foto app extended, ok, da muss jetzt ganz schön viel installieren, wir hauen einfach
mal alles drauf was geht, funktioniert die app auch am handy, für das meiste was ich
gesehen hab gibt's handy apps ja, auf dem fall jetzt keine ahnung, gleich ist er am
limit, leben am limit, 8-90% cpu, ich greif mal kurz auf die cpu drauf, warte mal kurz,
bis sie warm, bis sie warm ist, liegt, oh nein, schon wieder, was macht meine ubuntu installation,
die kogas so vor sich hin, gut, dass das jetzt, dass ne vm nebenbei auf so nem dualcore system
nicht so wahnsinnig schnell funktioniert, das wundert mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt, na,
das ist ja auch, man darf nicht vergessen, wie gut das hier läuft, obwohl ich nebenbei
noch mal ne ubuntu vm installiere, der mag sein dicker arme, das hab ich schon lang nicht
mehr gehört, das war immer so der running gag auf youtube, das ist der running gag auf
youtube, nee, mal wann zeigt zylwana ihre tippen, ok, der basti ew hat schon ausprobiert,
das sagt, es funktioniert alles gut, was an basic funktion da ist, kann man eigentlich
das neue dann schon installieren, was ist das, das ist dsm, was, dsm 6.2, gibts denn schon
dsm 7, dsm 8, nee dsm 8 gibts nicht, dsm 7, xpnology, geht das auch schon, achso, ok,
das geht aktuell nicht, das läuft damit noch nicht, also dsm 7 geht, oh guck mal, dsm 7
reviews, das ist ganz neu, ok, das gibts anscheinend noch nicht, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, 6.2 forever, ist das
nur ein dude, der die ganzen bootloader erstellt, das mein, das gibts doch so, da gibts doch
tausende user, dass da nicht noch mehr dabei sind, uns gehts allen gut nipples, aber wahrscheinlich
nicht mal so lang, weil ich nicht mal allzu lang streamen werde, ich hab heute morgen
schon drei stunden und jetzt nochmal, wo sind das, wirklich, wo sind das 250 on, ich hätte
jetzt gedacht schon länger, 6.2 ist alt, was gabs denn da vor, dsm 6, ok 6.3, nö, das
war bis eben das aktuelle, ok, der ubuntu saver braucht mir zu lang, das ganze, das ganze
breche ich jetzt ab, ok, das können wir jetzt nochmal aufdrehen, wie man vms ausschalten
kann, schaltet man vms einfach aus, ja, connect, action, force shutdown, bam, zack, jetzt hatte
ich hier ein bisschen mehr cpu, jetzt kann ich hier ein bisschen mehr cpu verwenden,
für das, für das andere zeug zum installieren, ja 7 gibts mittlerweile, aber wenn 7 gerade
erst rausgekommen ist, da war doch 6.2 aktuell bis quasi vor nem monat oder zwei, starting,
ok jetzt ist er fertig, was, control panel, user advanced, user advanced, ok, ok, ok, ok,
was soll ich aktivieren, user home, alles klar exquisite, hab ich gemacht, wie sieht
denn, wie sieht denn das 7 aus, sieht es noch besser aus, ich mein die oberfläche ist wirklich
schon ziemlich poggers, ja ein bisschen anders, ach das andere erkennt er nicht, pepe please,
ja das muss da rein unbedingt, ja voll, guck mal der kann sogar gifs, ok das ist im browser,
natürlich kann der gifs, das hat mit dem backend gar nichts zu tun, aber der kann gifs, so
kann der, wie upload ich denn jetzt hier was, kxor, wunderbar, das funktioniert wirklich
ausgesprochen gut, guck mal hier man kann sogar rotaten, nee kann man nicht, oh man kann
sogar rotaten, kann man auch croppen oder so, nee das geht nicht oder, croppen kann
man nicht, das wäre zu pro, interessant also das ding hat mich wirklich beeindruckt, muss
ich sagen kommt nicht oft vor, aber ziemlich poggers das ding, also ich bin wirklich hart
am überlegen das zu benutzen, gut leute ich geh jetzt was essen, ich hab hunger, genug
gestreamsort für heute, wir sehen uns dann morgen oder so, bis dann machts gut, cu